this is the state of play here in Port
Sudan right now hundreds of people
sleeping rough trying to get shade from
the sun it's scorching heat temperatures
up to 40 degrees waiting for any
opportunity to get to the other side to
get to safety to get to Saudi Arabia or
anywhere else they can be that isn't
Sudan during this time of deadly
conflict a Saudi Arabian vessel is
expected to arrive today and many people
come here to register for that
evacuation route but they can only
register if they're foreign Nationals if
they have residency in Saudi Arabia or
if they have a valid Visa or pilgrimage
visa and so many people have been able
to go but again many more are here
unable to evacuate unable to find safety
and they're from all over the world from
everywhere in the world Sudan hosted a
number of refugees from Syria and Yemen
and it has you know a wide a wide range
of cultures and people and to see them
here fleeing conflict again searching
for safety again is just heartbreaking
it's it's just dire it's absolutely dire
and the support here is is invisible
there's no humanitarian relief there are
no free free supplies there's no water
there's no no sign of any of the ngos
that operated in Sudan for so long none
of them are here they've all been
evacuated from here and again the the
community is the only thing that has
been keeping people here safe and
together people Sudanese people in Port
Sudan have opened up their city it's
essentially the new capital of the
country it's where so many people are
moving in thousands now that flight
evacuation has become so incredibly
dangerous yesterday we saw a Turkish a
Turkish military plane hit by gunfire
hit by fire as it was Landing in Wood
seed in a military base now that's the
base that's been used by a lot of
European embassies by the British
Embassy to evacuate people now they told
everyone to come here and try and find
safe passage via the sea from Port Sudan